I have to say I just told everyone how
excited I was to meet you we're all so
thrilled you're here oh I'm thrilled to
be here hi everybody hi
what great audience thank you so wait
okay you had a you did the wacky wire
game what first of all what is that I
don't even know
I was I was a law student at the time
but we took a summer out and it was a
work exchange program and all my buddies
went to work in the carnival and the
next man that I'm standing behind is
wackyard which is a wire that goes down
like this with a board behind and you
have to take a loop a metal Loop and and
take around that Loop without touching
the wire and if you touch it it's over
and if you if you uh don't touch it you
weren't the biggest teddy bear in the
fair
it's sort of like
operation you know that game where like
if you touch the metal and the first
person that came on was that came up to
play with a little kid and he just
walked up and he gave me two dollars and
then he and I'm like I can't do this I
just can't take people's money this is
awful would have felt so bad a few days
later I was like hey kiddo give me that
money come on the biggest teddy bear in
the fair
well okay so how I didn't know this
about you you were a fully fledged
lawyer like a real lawyer like a lawyer
yeah I was like a lawyer I'm just a
lawyer I was like nope that's actually
not true oh not well it's mostly true I
I went through law school I got a honors
law degree I got a diploma in legal
practice I did my two years training to
become a lawyer and minus a week
and and I wasn't doing very well I hated
what I was doing I want to be an actor
and about a week before they sat me down
they said this isn't really for you is
it you know this is not really what you
want to do go and and I became the first
trainee lawyer in the history of the
Scottish legal system to be fired so I'm
kind of proud of that
but the next day I packed my bags moved
to London and that was it that's I said
this is and in a way I've been released
to do what I want to do okay so I was
looking at your IMDb and but it was like
a while before 300. you know you had
been in the business for a while but
then when that movie hits oh my God it
hit so hard
such a major movie it's not only a box
office success it's like a cult classic
at the same time it's like it's
everything yeah because it fires you up
to whatever you know what are we gonna
do I I don't know
I love it
true that like this is Sparta was a line
in the script but it's really you that
like gave it that energy in life what
possessed well yeah because I was you
know we'd have that conversation you go
you know this is madness and now it's a
Madness this is Sparta boom I did a few
takes like that one a little
I I did I did one a little louder and
and then we then scene was done and they
were moving on the guys are kind of in
the camera away oh God no no no no no no
wait wait wait wait because I suddenly
thought what about the wildness in these
men there's a wildness and a surprise
and it's like I can have that
conversation and then you go oh this is
who they really are so they bring it
back I'm with Madness this is Sparta
boom and and it's been cut and I turn
around and everybody was laughing behind
me because it just seems so and I go
over to the director and I'm like that
was too much right it goes yeah but it
was awesome
um okay you're in this new action
thriller that I'm obsessed with plain um
we have a clip let's take a look
there is no full Rescue Team coming
anytime sir not for the next 24 hours
all right we can't wait they're gonna
come at us with everything they've got
and we're not gonna survive
no family and I managed to get the power
back up on the plane
I know we have one chance
and that is me flying is out of here on
this thing
I didn't even see that clip I luckily
watched the clip I've seen the film okay
so this film is so juicy I have to say
it really is it's like it just I don't
know it gives you all of that that yummy
stuff you crave when you go to an action
film
um did you do pilot training for this I
did do pilot training I spent a lot of
time
in a simulator I had two of the coolest
Pilots with me all the time really yeah
they train me in the simulator so in the
simulator you really feel like you're
flying and and what you're looking at
digitally is so real you're watching
cars under 405 I passed my old house I
went under the Hollywood Sign I'm taking
the photos I'm flying the plane going
look this is me the Hollywood Sign
because in a lot of the movie It's
you're flying you know basically it's
like a 737 over the ocean onto the
island looking for looking for a place
to land in the jungle and they're over
back out in the ocean back
um so that's what I was doing in L.A I
was flying over the 405 the 101 because
if you're playing the pilots wanna you
wanna immerse the audience in this world
and I feel like those scenes you really
feel like you're in that cockpit with us
going through the storm yeah and make
the decisions that we make because this
guy is a hero but he's not he's a
regular guy he's like what is that what
are these situations pull out of you
when an ordinary person is suddenly
finds himself in these extraordinary
situations and that's I love making
those movies where the flesh and blood
they make mistakes you know he doesn't
get it right this guy but he tries
[Music]